quatre courts couverts et quatre courts
extérieurs vont prendre place à
elancourt d'ici la fin de l'année
objectif renouveler l'offre tennistique
et les infrastructures actuelles devenu
vétuste
ici par exemple nous sommes dans
l'actuelle halles qui a plus de 30 ans
de d'âge et à différentes problématiques
d'étanchéité d'humidité dont qui rend
très difficile la pérennité d'une
pratique du tennis
les travaux devraient durer dix mois de
nouvelles infrastructures qui répondront
à des exigences environnementales pour
cela différents choix technique de
matériaux ont été opérées nous sommes
orientés sur une charpente en bois en
lamellé collé exactement sapin mélèzes
qui seront de provenance française
nous nous dirigeons vers une conception
où il n'y aura pas donc de chauffage
dans la halle principale couvertes mais
au contraire une gestion de l'humidité
de la ventilation qui sera pilotée avec
une isolation qui sera tout à fait
importantes y compris jusqu'aux bad et
des fondations
le futur complexe tennistique restera
implanté au parc des sports guy boniface
d'elancourt
il prendra place sur un ancien terrain
de football et il nous a paru important
de replacer le complexe au tennis tic
sur cet emplacement lors qu'ils
n'avaient plus vraiment d'utilité
objectif transférer l'activité tennis et
d'ici la fin d'année 2021 pour libérer
les bâtiments actuellement occupé par le
club
ils seront ensuite détruit pour
accueillir le projet de commissariats
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines budget total
du projet 3 8 millions d'euros